[Applause]
let's talk about uh what's happening in
australia a lot of people have been
dming me i'm sure they've been dming you
guys and like please talk about what's
happening here in australia yeah um
there are crazy wildfires
that are
there is that what's happening uh
spiders too there's bad spikes there's
spiders there but wait is it still on
fire or it's stopped to fire no stop
yeah i think i think lou spears put out
the fire with this
his donation remember he had the special
and he that was yeah okay so lose lose
spears put out the fire shout sue lewis
um no but what's really going on in
australia we have a video we're gonna
watch
here is the video go legislation passed
in parliament will give police
unprecedented powers to tackle criminals
on the dark web including pedophiles and
traffickers but critics warn it turns
australia into a surveillance state and
intrudes on the privacy of everyday
citizens okay so
so um
any expansion of government power is a
uh comes at a direct cost of democracy i
think that's what that guy said yeah and
obviously that's the issue here and
let's say let's look at two things best
case scenario
these people want to get pedophiles out
of there right we all support that right
you're like how the [ __ ] do you get
pedophiles out wait there's pedophiles
operating on the dark web well let's
create some sort of legislation that
allows you to go after pedophiles i
think everybody supports that yeah
worst case scenario
an overbearing state department is using
pedophilia as a way to get more control
over the populace yes and i think that's
what a lot of people are concerned about
it's like hey we want pedophiles to [ __ ]
out of here too do whatever you got to
do to get out of the get the pedophiles
out of here you know what they're doing
on the dark web change their data hack
into their phones do whatever the [ __ ]
you got to do shoot them in the forehead
we're all supportive the concern is well
once you're doing for that
do you start doing it for people who are
you know parking illegal here's what got
me in i don't remember the exact words
but they said something about the data
law and it said you know uh if there's
suspicious you know suspicious activity
such as child pornography such as means
we could do whatever we want this is
just one example of okay activity we
don't i said child pornography and other
crimes and other crimes so what if
okay so what if for example
it was isolated to a few crimes it was
isolated to child pornography
human trafficking
terrorism
and what if it was only those three
things and let's have uh you know open
discussion about it right uh because i
understand if it's child pornography and
other crimes they're basically using
child pornography as a smoke screen to
go into every one of your phones and say
hey you patriot are you downloading some
illegal videos hey did you not pay your
[ __ ] parking tickets hey um are you
selling alcohol out of your bar
that you haven't been approved by the
state to sell right like they can go
after an illegal poker game that you're
having with your friends they can do
anything they want but they're using
pedophilia as the smokes
smoke screen it's like you're not even
really trying to help pelvic stop
pedophilia which i'm really trying to do
is just arrest as many people are
breaking the law as possible and maybe
they start to use it for covet stuff i
mean
australia is shutting down it feels like
every couple weeks right there's a few
cases that pop up and all of a sudden
they shut the whole [ __ ] city down so
are they going to start tracking people
who may or may not have covid may or may
not be in contact with people to covet
and then just start arresting them and
putting them you know i don't know even
in jail or in these forced quarantines
right and those all those cases are even
just like semi-justified
you know breaking of the law or like
moral misconduct or whatever you want to
call it but like we've also seen all
these other cases where they just take
out people that they don't like
to be that that are causing issues for
the state you know what i mean so
i mean there's a million documentaries
like making a murderer whatever else
like where people are unjustly
prosecuted and put in jail because
either one the state doesn't like them
the local community doesn't like them or
because of some other like outlying
factor like race or whatever else so
this is this is very interesting if you
don't isolate the crimes to the big
three or whatever you are or whatever
you say even if you do it even if you do
but let's say for example you isolate if
you don't if there is some wiggle room
for other crimes to go in there let's
say there's a politician you don't like
they're getting a lot of support
you pop on their laptop you find out oh
he's downloading uh torrents
of these movies he's doing some illegals
he has child porn on his computer like
you can put it on there under this new
bill oh you're changing their data so
you can place you can add and delete
evidence at police as well according to
what they just said in the video oh
that's that's [ __ ] up i don't want
anybody to be able to add some [ __ ] to
me yeah that seems highly i think that's
how we're interpreting it but i don't
think they just said they can take
control of your social accounts before
they had to have access and approval
you're not saying they're doing it but
they can i think they were saying oh we
can take control of this person's social
account if this person's known to like
be the middleman to
for sex trafficking and use that account
to catch other people i think i think
best case scenario is and that's what
they're saying about change data meaning
you can start interacting with other
people let's say you're running a child
sex trafficking ring they could take
control of your account use that account
to find all these other people that
you're doing this child sex trafficking
with and then arrest all of them as well
that's best case scenario worst case
scenario
this power in the wrong hands and we
know that power corrupts ultimate power
corrupts uh was absolute power
absolutely or whatever it is from animal
farm it's like we know a politician
might be like yo put some [ __ ] on that
motherfucker's phone it doesn't have to
be child porn it could be some real like
dark uh you know weird dark web
pornography it could be like who knows
what the [ __ ] it is right it could be
something like
legal-esque
you know like a little bit legal a
little bit illegal something you
wouldn't want a politician to have on
their laptop and that could be put there
yeah and there might be no way to prove
it it isn't there and that's why you
have to like safeguard from these laws i
understand the concern people have there
yeah 100 yeah and then the issue with
the terrorism thing is what happened to
this kid friendly geordies and this is
the thing that i brought up before
what's that so this is i'm pulling this
information this is like a news article
i didn't listen before so it could seem
interesting
yeah on purpose this is like a bridge
from a news article that's on reddit but
basically what happened with this kid
friendly geordies he was a youtuber in
australia and he accused a prominent
politician of corruption so basically he
backed up his claims he had substantial
evidence all this other [ __ ] saying that
this politician was corrupt and that he
lied and they had all his like previous
times where he lied and like crossed
himself and all this other [ __ ] and
other times that he's corrupt the
politician then puts the australian
anti-terrorist police squad on friendly
geordies and his 20 year old producer
basically saying like this guy is making
threats against me he's encouraging
violence against me he's spreading
misinformation and defamation against me
you guys got to go investigate him so
basically the anti-terror squad goes up
to his house in plain clothes
goes through the door injures the mom
almost kills the family dog tackles him
to the ground takes him off in an
unmarked police car also sees the phone
and they have all legal access to access
the phone and all the other data on the
phone and the computer
and so then the case goes before the
court and in america we'd be like no you
can't do that you can't go into the
phone without access whatever whatever
because we have rights and [ __ ] and then
in front of the court the defense was
like yeah this is ridiculous he
the judge rules that the politician did
not lie and thus was not corrupt and
because he's a politician he's able to
lie in parliament
and that's what they call parliamentary
privilege if you're lying in order to
like preserve you know the state
and so he was found guilty of defamation
and so the politician admitted that he
called the
anti-terrorism squad in his witness
statement and now people are looking at
this and they're like okay so they
intimidated this kid made an example of
this kid because he was talking [ __ ]
about the politicians and now they have
all this additional access that they
didn't have before they're like what the
[ __ ] never underestimate all right guys
we're gonna take a break from this
exclusive patreon clip to tell you how
to make money gambling and the way you
do is you do it mybookie.ag it's
mybookie.ag and i'm gonna tell you
exactly why you can do it because
they're gonna double that initial
deposit up to a thousand dollars i don't
know why you would gamble with anybody
else you just gotta use the promo code
flagrant they're gonna double the
initial deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars that's a free one thousand
dollars that you get to gamble with why
would you gamble anywhere else very
simple mybookie.ag you know what we got
we got football we got ufc we got
absolutely everything you could think of
mybookie.ag and they're giving you money
to make the money you're crazy if you
don't do it mybookie.ag
make sure you use that promo code
flagrant and they're gonna double your
initial deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars you are [ __ ] welcome matter
of fact you should cut me in anyway
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
never underestimate uh what a man is
willing to do to ensure his salvation
and when it comes to politicians like
you have to understand the second you
become a politician you are doing [ __ ]
that's corrupt i don't care if it's aoc
i don't care if it's abide i don't care
if it's trump i don't care any
politician is involved in some level of
corruption right and they might have
some protection they might give the
rights for someone to start building in
downtown miami now they know who they're
giving those rights to they might know
that they're giving the rights to some
real mafia guys but they're like hey
listen they support the campaign they
seem like good guys but they know what's
going on yeah and they know where the
privilege is bestowed right how did the
politicians get there they got money
from corporations and now you're talking
hella [ __ ] about the corporations and
the guy goes yo can you handle this the
corporation taps the shoulder of the
politician what the [ __ ] is this guy
doing he's killing us he's putting all
this misinformation they made blackfish
saying that we're killing [ __ ] whales
at sea world can you handle this
raytheon taps you on the shoulder hey
we're going to need you to do us a favor
a lot of people talking [ __ ] about our
company we understand we make missiles
but we make other [ __ ] too and we don't
want people to stop buying our [ __ ] just
because we make some missiles for you
guys to go to war and everybody makes it
so like epstein could literally be like
yo this journalist is kicking around my
door trying to interview people like can
you just do it they did that already so
imagine having like political power to
do it yeah i guess exactly like these
politicians that helped out epson had to
take a risk and it ended up hurting
their careers what's the guy [ __ ]
costco or whatever his name is
yeah acosta costa yeah like that guy i
mean it killed his per career as it
should have the [ __ ] should be
in prison but the point is now you can
do with impunity that's dangerous
and and we always and that's why we got
to be careful when like people put
through legislation that is tied into
uh
morality right like hey let's protect
the let's protect women and children
actually yeah like who's gonna say no to
that yeah but what else are you gonna
protect yeah with that act yeah and it's
really unfortunate because nobody wants
to be the politician or person in
journalism or news or even comedy that's
going against the let's protect the
women and children actually that's gonna
be the sword that you die on yeah the
let's protect the women and children act
yes
the one thing with that case where
and for some reason this it brought it
to mind was um when we had ack on the
pod yeah and he said [ __ ] about them and
then wheezy says some [ __ ] online and so
then act gets on his stream and starts
saying [ __ ] about weezy then all of axe
fans were like
copping in her dms threatened to rape
her kill her and all this type of stuff
yeah so
i can see a situation where like yo
because of what ax said on his stream
she's now getting death threats which is
a form of terrorism
because like you're encouraging violence
on this person right and i don't know
but yeah you have to be able to express
an opinion and not be held responsible
for people
he said go to page and tell this
[ __ ] um how dumb she is or something
like that right right so it's like
it's it's almost like the way that trump
did spelled out
whatever that's my girl you're quoting
him
so
it's almost like how trump was like oh
let's go and fight for our country you
know it's like yeah coded messages some
people can see it as like he inside
invited other people could just be like
no just go protest or whatever the case
so what you're trying to say is like
becoming being a terrorist or what is
terrorism is very vague yes and now
anything can be used in that way like
you say something in a song you're like
[ __ ] this block you know we coming at
you we're taking your heads off and all
of a sudden someone get killed on that
block it's like well they might have did
it because of the song you just put out
a little dirk i think we're gonna have
to arrest you a little dirk you saw what
happened because of what you said you
incited violence you incited terrorism
yeah like when that uh that white comics
you like had trump's head cut off and
[ __ ] like that and the [ __ ] feds came
up came for and [ __ ] like that so it's
like i can see how you can so now
anything can be terrorism on somebody
and fighting violence yeah so like that
situation even though i don't agree with
them going through his phone like if a
lot of his people were giving death
threats on his family and [ __ ] like that
like nah send the feds to his mother
grip but we don't have any evidence of
that and if all you're doing
hypothetically yeah these are
hypotheticals if you're calling for
action
then things might get hazy even if it's
hey just tell her she's stupid then it
might be a bit hazy if you're saying hey
go [ __ ] this [ __ ] up then that's a yeah
absolutely you should be prosecuted if
you're saying hey tell her she's stupid
maybe it's a bit hazy maybe it's a bit
blurry but if you're just saying hey
that [ __ ] is corrupt
and then people are threatening him you
can't be held responsible for presenting
what you believe is a fact yeah
i'm just saying like we don't know you
don't have like people to get their [ __ ]
to blow like they talk like [ __ ] wwe
wrestlers and [ __ ] like that so yeah you
never know if the way he was talking
could have been
also you can interpret anything said as
inciting violence yes and that's where
you have to attribute to power yeah stay
safe and that's where it gets very easy
to abuse the zombies yeah stay safe
could mean we're going to come kill you
yeah yeah that and that's where it's
tricky man and then also how do police
operate with that information like one
so i guess you're talking about a few
different things like one is like
internet like
you know being anonymous on the internet
and so like that's a different thing
than the cops being able to just like go
through your phone and see yeah and i'm
against going through the phone right
i'm not against the cops showing up to
his motherfucker's house if he incited
violence on that dude in his family but
how do we define inciting violence
that's what i'm saying i'm saying if he
said something in because he's a big
youtuber so i'm saying if he said like
yo [ __ ] that guy it's on site for him or
some [ __ ] like that and if they injured
the mom and almost killed a family dog
and then through you could also call say
police brutality pretty easily so like
yeah you could show up
sure but then you still handle it yeah
what is the extent of force like did
they have a warrant yeah are they
allowed 20 year old youtuber i'm
definitely i'm just throwing up
different playing devils
yeah right this is where it's tricky
though man this is where it's tricky and
then this is where it also gets tricky
is it's it's you're you're splitting
hairs when you say laws such as or child
pornography and other crimes you have to
be very that's where it becomes an abuse
of power to me is we're looking at these
other words that are they're just a few
words in a thing but they mean
everything yeah and other crimes means
everything that means anything that's a
crime we can do whatever we want
yeah you stole a [ __ ] jolly rancher
from a store when you were five years
old oh we need to look through all your
stuff so so do we allow um
i don't want to say abusive of power but
do we allow more access to our lives for
more severe crimes currently
so uh an example that apple they release
software into their phones it's going to
come with like the next uh software
update yeah where they have
they already have the ability to look
through all your pictures and scan it if
you have like more than like 30 child
pornography pictures or whatever the
case is they can report you to the
authorities so 29 29
basically yeah like they wanted besides
that number i don't know but they want
it to be like
clear cut situation because like what if
like
your boys are just sending you stupid
[ __ ] or whatever the case or you just
get a picture of your niece from your
brother and like you know or your you
know well their argument and i looked it
up is that if it's on icloud they're
able to no no even on your phone are you
sure oh yeah i made sure to get that one
so even before being uploaded to icloud
if you have more than 30 cases then
they'll say and is it just child porn
it's strictly chopper there's a
heinousness barrier that's just going
after pedophiles so i'm an all supporter
of that exactly there's a heinousness
barrier if it's past a certain point of
like a heinous crime like child
pornography terrorism we're like yeah
man do what you got to do yeah that's a
human thing that we all just kind of are
like yeah i mean yeah sure but when you
start playing with that then we get
uncomfortable
okay so
i'm with you 100 let's say we're all on
board with this uh this child
pornography thing right
uh
how many people does child pornography
affect
let's say like a very small small number
assuming a small number let's say way
more people die because of like drug
dealing
uh
murders
that are all planned and plotted using
your phone and if we had access to that
phone you could probably save so many
more lives there's so many people that
are being destroyed so many people
getting addicted to [ __ ] opiates so
many people planning robberies so many
businesses are destroyed like when does
it stop because we really want to save
lives as [ __ ] up as it is what i'm
about to say if we really want to save
lives focusing on
child porn pictures on a phone is not
the way to save lives like focusing on
stopping people from drunk driving like
if your phone could tell if you had a
few drinks that night you know if your
phone could tell you're over the limit
like if the goal is to save lives or if
the goal is to do something that like
you think will get like garner some sort
of a positive support on the internet oh
look at how noble apple is going after
child porn like are you doing it for
pats on the back or you do it because
you really want to stop this thing and
if you really want to stop people are
you basically going yeah we're okay
people are drunk driving killing
themselves that's not really what we're
about we want to stop people from having
child porn on the phone it's just weird
right it feels like there's some but
also the possession of the photographs
is legal in its own right whereas like
talking about doing a crime isn't
necessarily illegal in the same way
well that's not true because talking
about doing a crime is called uh
conspiracy
you'd have to prove it i guess but like
with the image of child porn like it is
intrinsically yeah that's if you're able
to that's fair to prove that it's on so
it's like slightly different what about
sorry interrupt but like what about uh
what about they could tell for whatever
reason that you've had a few drinks or
you've had ex you know yeah and once
then they can tell you're driving once
that technology is available they
probably yeah and that's quite possible
especially in a place like australia but
i think here the idea is it's not about
how many lives you save it's about
stopping the most [ __ ] up crimes what
up people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
you